you mentioned
anger when i watch your interviews
you're really calm and collected not
just your interviews
you know instagram the way you present
yourself you um
i don't know it seems like you're almost
at peace with the world
um is there in private times when you're
just angry
do you feel fear do you go to dark
places
depression all those kinds of things are
are you able to put that world that you
were in behind you
it's a joke because i talk about north
korea every single day
and i still rescue people like from
china
and russia and other countries right and
sometimes our rescue mission fails and
they get captured and send back
i still have people in north korea
report to me
so like when i talk to my sister who
chose to not
be in this life activist life she forgot
most of things
and like for the other hand i like
remember everything
so sometimes it's uh it's
it's a blessing to keep reminded of
how because it's you know they say
happiness relative thing
it is sometimes i mean a good thing is
also people say
because nobody was fooling when you're
growing up everybody was suffering
you should have been okay right but know
like if you
are suffering in that degree no matter
even if there's no comparison
if you're in nazi german in the
holocaust right in the concentration
camp
i'm sure nobody was better than them i'm
sure they were
suffering it's the same thing i suffered
but now because i'm in this place i can
compare
easily right getting that perspective
but it is true like i still have days
that i cannot get out of bed
and i'm really hoping like that where it
was
elamos talking about downloading your
brain blah blah
yeah like if maybe technology develops
that i can download some part of my
memory
and then i can erase it like when i
delete it
and that would be so much better what i
this is uh
sorry for the tough question but if i
came to you if elon
came to you and said we can erase that
part of your memory
would you do it some days i would do it
for sure
and my mom would do a hundred percent my
sister would do it
all other defectors know they do a
hundred percent
for me i hesitated because i'm a witness
so if i delete that part i don't know
how weird that can be
but it is painful like after i talk
give a speech right i mean i'm fine but
somehow i'm depressed
sometimes if the talk was very intense
i'm like depressed for three weeks
it takes a while for me to be recharged
but i don't know why
it is you know yeah i i just don't know
yeah well there's also the and uh
there's a guy named victor franco who
wrote the book command search for
meaning
and there's some aspect where so he
talks about the holocaust and
you can in the in those moments of
suffering still discover meaning
still discover happiness in the simplest
of joys
like while starving you know a little
piece of bread could be a source of
incredible joy yeah and there's some
aspect
in which that experience gives you a
clarity about the world
like somehow experiencing suffering
allows you to
deep deeply experience joy
yeah and love and
also empathize with the suffering of
others and like it's almost like
brings you closer to other humans so
it's
this double-edged sword that um
that the highest of joys sometimes
are catalyzed by suffering and it's hard
to know what to do with that you see
that with
world war ii the stories of soldiers
that have suffered but
some of the closest bonds um
of brotherhood of just pure love was
experienced by them
and it's it sucks that our brains are
like this
you know the love requires hardship i
don't know why that is
yeah that's like that's thing of course
in my journey i learned
how to survive right when to not trust
and meant to run but i think
most of i was keep learning what it
means to be a human being
i think that was like ultimate thing i
was keep learning and
i still don't know fully what it means
but i do think
it seems like suffering is necessary for
people to be grateful and even be joyful
to sometimes
you